oh baby the wait is over new dates added
on the middle class famous store gang
we're coming to see you bring the squad
out live stand up comedy show play a
little energy with the crowd great way
to introduce some people to the show
bring the squad out Kippy straighten
these bozos out in November we have two
shows in Atlanta as part of the red clay
Comedy Festival get those tickets then
we're going to Charlotte North Carolina
also we have a sold out show in
Philadelphia Two Sold Out shows in
Philadelphia sorry smell you next time
Philly uh Providence Rhode Island we
just had a second Show tickets available
in December Boston the same thing we had
in the second Show tickets still
available get those tickets those shows
will sell out we'll see you there see ya
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the group to be classy yeah go
to just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host Dave Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
Antonio's basement she's upstairs
arguing with the mailman oh no trying to
get him to pay for a plan B that they uh
made an arrangement on all right okay
fair enough my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me I really mailed
that one in he's the CEO of Ru garbage
I'm not giving you anything he's the CEO
of Ru garbage he's an international
businessman he's the prince of Park
Avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk baby give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan Hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure your rate if
you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are turning around cooking and
then obviously the greatest goddamn
website of all [ __ ] time
www.patreon.com
check it the [ __ ] out gang it's a party
over there write it down copy and paste
whatever you got to do go check it out
gang and how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire he's
back with us he's feeling better but
next episode he's going to be going
again so he might get sick next week
give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dude
we got the podfather the OG East Coast
dawn of Dons looking a little true over
there
I'm chubbing up I gotta be honest I'm
surprised he didn't come in a two-piece
showing them off a little bit gang we
couldn't be more excited to have her
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us to get today for the
second and third time he's back with us
um had a [ __ ] fantastic summer this
guy just to let you know you can check
him out in the brand new movie Fourth of
July the [ __ ] box office summer
[ __ ] smashed you can check them out
in all five seasons of Louis and he also
has a brand new special out right now
called Robert Kelly kill box you can get
that all at Louis ck.net give it up for
the new and improved the 2.0 Robert
Kelly everybody the six the six skinny
the six and it's uh Louis ck.com is it I
thought it was Louis ck.net I don't know
I think it is Louis ck.com I'm pretty
sure I'm right just [ __ ] Google it
out there pretty sure if you're wrong
I'm making eat a whole Hoagie if you're
wrong
I'll throw up I can't eat I know you
can't do it I gotta [ __ ] you've lost
your superpowers
that's louisck.com folks what the [ __ ]
he must have changed Louis now now you
have to eat a whole okay he already was
planning on it so we're good I'm gonna
be two on the day all right what's up
Louis ck.com ladies and gentlemen the
skinny minis over here you know what I
mean dude the spiral fold is gonna go
through on this episode
[Laughter]
my tongue removed next week I think
you're gonna one up me what are you nuts
still manage to get better somehow
now there's more it doesn't get the food
doesn't eat ah [ __ ] God damn it I
couldn't get that out here way to go
Bozo I was good I was putting together
it was like the Matrix I just couldn't
get there bozo is my favorite Bozo and
dud oh God yeah I love when calling who
someone I think Colin called uh Joe
DeRosa a dude somebody boss's roast it
was like Joey Rose is just a dud it was
the most perfect word for him that's
great but buddy congratulations
everything thank you very much brand new
special kill box will we say Louis
ck.com that's correct [ __ ]
unbelievable you filmed it down here in
Florida we did it down in Florida at
Coastal creatives uh and Saint Pete
because you know Florida was the place
uh that kind of saved my life during the
pandemic because they didn't shut the
down I went down there and I just did
show after show I'm sure and those
people just showed the [ __ ] up yeah yeah
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah Side
Splitters so yeah it was it was fun plus
you know Mike caught them my number one
best friend
he uh we sold it out in five minutes two
shows all of them on I mean they're just
the crowds down there just support me so
it was it was epic it was great we made
the space uh we went into that empty
it's just blank space and we went in
there and I told them what I wanted to
do and Louie he's just a [ __ ] genius
his team too he put me he gave me his uh
his guys he didn't give me like locals
you didn't get the B Squad I got the got
the Heavy Hitters yeah like the set
designer has a [ __ ] Emmy damn you
know what I mean like all the people
there like Emmy award-winning you know
Grammys all the [ __ ] with him so it was
pretty great to uh got some leftover
Roadie from sticks or something like
that yeah like some local guy some meth
head sound guy yeah you'll be fine
stealing the equipment and stuff they
don't need to hear you I can hear it
through the I can hear it you're good
yeah it was it was it was [ __ ]
unbelievable now I just saw the cut that
Louis edited it he directed it uh so uh
I just saw it it looks [ __ ] great we
just wanted to I'm a club comic you know
what I mean you guys we're club guys
going to these clubs and [ __ ] murder
and we wanted to recreate a holy [ __ ]
the club special like sure the theater
specials the first special was that or
not your first whatever the last one
though live from the village underground
that was the same that I also you know
nerd out for a second that was one
nobody really had done it in a club like
that at that point like at least or that
one really like a high level of
production yeah I was like oh you're
[ __ ] you're in it like it feels like
you're sitting in the room rather than
watching people watch this well up until
that point and you're a nerd you're a
nerd you'll know we couldn't do it the
cameras were too big of course so you
couldn't do this oh yeah but then at
that point they came out those cannons
but in that special you know Jim Serpico
and uh figured it out where someone was
by the you had to shut the camera off
every 15 minutes so you had there was
people by every camera shutting it off
going to another camera and turning it
back on because they just didn't record
that video for that long so it was
pretty epic how they did it but that
special was awesome awesome this one
Louis was just I had two hours because I
no one give me a special nobody I you
know nobody would be like uh which is
crazy because you kill I mean if you ask
anybody in New York or even like any you
know big you kill harder than probably
anybody yeah but that don't matter I
know I'm just saying but that's it's
crazy because you're that fun like yeah
a murderer it's a weird thing like you
always thought that you come up and you
you're you're one of the funniest guys
in the room and you'll get stuff but
that's not the case the fastest horse
doesn't win the ratio of this business
but I don't hate the people I get it
sure whatever the [ __ ] reasons God
bless them but Louie I tore with him in
March and he came off after my Set uh
he's like dude what the [ __ ] are you do
you have a special and I was like no no
give me one he goes I'm doing you
[ __ ] special I'm doing it you should
have a special I'm gonna do that and he
did it a lot of people say [ __ ] like
that but he actually did him Leah I mean
that I I was I was you know and I told
him what I wanted too and he actually
did that you you know he put the money
so I need you to buy it because I got to
pay Louie back I know that
motherfucker.com I mean that we need to
get his money back you know what I mean
we gotta recoup yeah I don't know if I
don't know if that boys are in a red I
don't know if that movie did it but so I
gotta do it you know what I mean I don't
want to see Louie [ __ ] doing headline
spots and [ __ ] you know Jacksonville
yeah Louie's in Poughkeepsie next
weekend he's doing laughing up yeah he's
got he's got just a payback [ __ ] my
stupid special doing 19 shows at the
train station I just kidding I love we
love that show there's such you have to
say that I know I know yeah I did say it
I didn't mention somebody Ari was on
here and I mentioned a club or something
I was like what the [ __ ] like where
it's a comedy podcast yeah also the club
stunk
I didn't lie
stay at the club again come on uh no I'm
not I'm not Gary what does it sound like
uh schmies crackers
laughs
I want it all I want all the smoke today
boys let's go well you stink too
go back to dot net what are you doing
making me look like an [ __ ] it was
Louis ck.net for a while yeah back in
the 60s I mean what the [ __ ] who
uses.net well he was the first guy on
the internet
but buddy an amazing summer you look
absolutely fantastic thank you how
um what has changed other what has
changed in your life other than that
your dressing get some new gear you get
a whole new wardrobe I mean what are you
doing yeah what are you down to by the
way what's the X in front of you I have
uh I can do an XL real that's a big trap
this is too big so I was 3XL tea you
have to do the T sure to talk because
when you do this thank you good night
yeah I did that one night with the red
belly button yeah dude it came out and I
just saw the girl in the front row like
what the [ __ ] is that that throws up
like a dog [ __ ] belly button hernia
just came out her [ __ ] cheese sticks
shot out of her mouth I think you got
meatloaf under your shirt
looks like a ham
I stole a ham it's not just fat it does
get it does get wild the veins and the
and the crevices and the cracks and the
way this
is your belly button you have a [ __ ]
scoop on your belly button oh all the
time I mean just stuff comes out of
there yeah I had a piece of cheese mine
smells like cheese a lot It might smell
that but I didn't know I don't know if
it was cheese I made in my belly button
or was cheese that fell in my belly
button if it was outdoor cheese you're
not sure I don't know if it was yeah I
don't know if it was baby Bell Bobby
over here
look at Cooper sharp in there yeah no
everything my my dude the chicks at home
are probably touching themselves right
now
ladies take a cold shower
yeah I can I do the the greatest thing
so far are you pants over the belly now
I never did that what are you doing it
now though right I I don't do that
really no I can't I still have a bit I I
have I know people who do the I'm over
the belly I don't do that I I think
that's a cheat and I feel weird after
whatever I'm smoking mirrors here I did
I can do I couldn't do it before if I
did it before I'd look like Johnny
Arbuckle or whatever his name was but
now I can kind of do it John Arbuckle I
don't know what his name is
no I go I go on there I I could never go
I felt weird pulling it up you do it and
when you do it
sorry like I saw you we were at the pool
the other day you were doing oh that was
a big it looks like it looks like we're
the wrong bathing suit normally it looks
like you're from 1922. when you do it by
the way
in bathing suit situations I normally
don't I normally don't do it but I
grabbed the wrong bathing suit so I did
it and yeah it's a tough look at a
[ __ ] hotel you're you're like a you
you're a Hollywood fat like you're
Jackie Gleason fat I was like everybody
wears their fat different I I was just
all belly I had that Irish [ __ ] up fat
I had these little I had the legs of
like an 87 year old woman from Worcester
Massachusetts
yeah well that's good that's because
you're [ __ ] working out all the time
carrying that torso around you know what
I mean I should have had big legs too I
was a I was 350 dude yeah three [ __ ]
50. bigger than any uh I was bigger than
any uh heavyweight champ I was bigger
than most defensive lines at five eight
and uh it was done I mean my knees were
going and my feet would tangling my
liver was fatty I mean I you know I was
going to be uh one of those guys you
were cruising I was I was you going to
be talking about me you're gonna have a
special episode dedicated to Bob and
Keith was going to happen yeah picking
up all those Louis parts
shave your head immediately
how fun how funny if I lose all the
weight and he doesn't use me uses you
now yeah Bobby you were my go-to fat guy
that's my whole plan because we were
talking about on the phone the other day
like hey I got to do it too I gotta do
I'm just waiting for you to get real
skinny everybody else to get real skinny
I'm the only fat guy in town well now
I'm gonna stay like this I'm not losing
it anyway
what are you doing for the oh for the
Wardrobe re-kick are you going at it one
day and buy like a bunch yeah you have I
don't know if that was what you were
wearing but you had like uh like a
finance bro kind of vest on your episode
with Greg stone that you did on uh yeah
on your pod yeah are you are you
upgrading a little bit no not yet I know
but yeah the idea if he's gonna get
smaller everything he buys is in a 2X or
an X when it gets down to a large it's
all out there I went to Walmart like a
month ago dancer Benjamin Button yeah
you only got this this is a shelf life
on those t-shirts hold on you went to
Walmart dude I went to Walmart and
bought 400 worth of [ __ ] outfits
that's smart yeah because you're in a
holding 17 000
he owns the Walmart
I bought 400 with the clothes at Walmart
I'm telling you I went to Walmart and
bought my my wife was like we get you
new stuff I'm gonna go to Walmart I
ain't [ __ ] spending money and it's
not gonna fit in a in a month or two and
what's a trajectory right now you're
down what so you were you were you were
350 when you got when you went in when I
went in I was 335 because you have to
lose you have to lose a certain amount
of weight you can't just go in you can't
just call a doctor up and go get it done
like a teeth cleaner we talked about
that we talked about that am I gonna get
my BMI down if I was going to consider
doing that you got to go in you you meet
with the nutritionist you gotta uh go to
a hot guy get your heart checked out and
then get your BMI down to a certain
percentage okay before they go in and
then that I got down to 335. so you went
from 350 to 335 350 335 and now the last
time I weighed myself was uh
I think I was
353 uh 58. wait when 250 258 258. Jesus
no two 65. okay sorry sorry 265. I think
but I don't weigh myself do they say
what you could be looking at like where
are you 200 that's right so 200 by when
roughly end of the year end of the year
you're 200. then you'll go and get to
get the stuff what's oh the close close
I'll get new clothes at when I settle I
will get new clothes at then either I
got to make sure the reason why I didn't
even tell anybody about this because I
didn't you know I didn't want I didn't
know what was going to happen I didn't
know it was a it was a big decision you
know because you you want to do it
yourself you want to just go to the gym
eat right you know what the [ __ ] to do
sure and you want to do it yourself but
I couldn't this time I've done it six
times before I just couldn't do it this
time so I looked at it like um over
people that don't know we didn't even
talk about it Bobby uh has mesothelioma
yeah I'm dying I'm dying right now part
of a big lawsuit coming in and I have
set when he's gonna buy his clothes not
at Walmart once that money land I have
sepsis too from a pimple there my nut I
popped it just didn't hear right so oh
really no wow that was a little too true
yeah yeah not a little too accurate
I didn't get an infection from it I just
popped it sepsis
well you had the sleeve done I had a
gastric sleeve which is there's three
things there's the the gastric bypass
where they rearrange your whole [ __ ]
it's a big procedure the little uh ring
or whatever the [ __ ] they call it band
uh and then the sleeve where they just
make your stomach the size of a banana
and it's it's not invasive it's a
laparoscopic uh it's like a three hour
surgery you're walking around that night
but I was looking at it how do they get
because I saw they do the little holes
and they go in like that yeah how do
they get the sleeve out of there how do
they get the rest of the stomach they
take it out uh through one they have a
little incision there your belly button
they just take out they suck that
stomach right out and throw it in a pan
where'd that go they feed it the
seagulls
I used it to catch crab took it to
Cooperstown no my guy made sausages with
him
Bobby haggis
it's a good sausage they gave Bobby the
sleeve they'd have to give you the whole
shirt oh holy [ __ ] bring in a [ __ ]
Taylor on a board maybe I'll wear that
wear a fully suit lap band suit yeah
that's awesome so you have so you do
that and then 200 pounds man well I
didn't lose 200 no I'm saying you're
gonna you're gonna be at 200. I'll do
200 I'll probably lose yeah I'll
probably be like uh maybe a little under
we'll see 130 but it had to be done now
since then my heart my blood pressure is
normal okay liver normal uh uh
pre-diabetic insulin levels normal all
my aches and pains are gone sleep apnea
is gone I sleep now at night I actually
get rested what are you gonna do with
them out front he wrote up on a
skateboard that's how young he feels
yeah the two kickflips they gave me a
wedgie
what about the let's talk about the most
important thing what what's the little
guy like the U days you got a little
life back in them let me tell you
something man does he get a little more
Wiggle two things happen a lot of stuff
happened that I was like this is awesome
you know tie my shoe in the middle sure
actually tying my shoe yeah uh like
standing up tying my shoe oh [ __ ]
nuts in the middle I gotta go on the I
gotta use the bed to put my socks on I
gotta it's starting to get better now
but I a couple months ago
yesterday in the airport all's I hear is
[ __ ]
I go do you want to find do you want to
take care of that because no I don't
want to do anything about it I'm like
all right man I have to wait to get to
Cleveland dude I got kizzix the slippins
I was I was like [ __ ] this is the
best thing ever made just slip them in
but no uh the two things that were
incredible was uh I was up in the tiny
house and I took a shower and I was I
washed my balls from the back
you know because to clean get soap in
your ass I would get hurt like I'd have
to you know dislocate my [ __ ]
shoulder sure and put it like just you
know like a bear rubbing on a tree wait
can you do that you're skinny can you
reach behind your thing and grab your
balls yeah dog you can you can't right I
think my arms are too short even when
I'm less skinny or my balls are too
tight look at I made this some crispy
this time's longer than this arm from
wiping my ass I literally are you being
serious I swear dude I I can only wipe
my ass with my left because I somehow
stretched this out enough Bobby can't go
right I can't I could never wipe my ass
with my right I can't reach my ball bag
from the back ah I can't you all hooker
it's like
Reflections injury that's crazy
I thought you were goddamn favorite
Copperfield out here
[Laughter]
I opened the shower I was like dog that
guy was giving himself reach around you
I go dog get in here she's like what I'm
just holding my nuts they're all soapy
I'm like look what I could do okay let's
talk about movement
yeah let's talk about a couple of guys
just like us you got nothing to lose a
couple of college dropouts he turned the
watch game upside down on its head
underneath boom they stuck them they
moved they keep it going a couple of
rule Breakers grew into one of the
biggest watch brands out there serving
150 countries now they got all kinds of
stuff over there it's a good time yeah
uh the good folks over there movement
were nice enough to send us a bunch of
fresh [ __ ] gear I got my nice going
out watch when me and a bird we throw on
something sexy go out to dinner you know
what I mean I flashed a watch on the
waiter and I go you probably think this
is a couple hundred bucks wrong fraction
of the price I lost the blue light
glasses they got the blue light glasses
they sent us when you're looking when
I'm watching my movies when you're
watching the screens that much it blocks
out the blue light the whole nine yards
of science behind it these guys got it
all figured out plus you look [ __ ]
cool yeah like a little tint
um you'll get a beautiful watch or glass
to ship right to your door for free and
if you don't love it you can ship it
back for free as well
um if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank then
join movement and get 15 percent off
today with free shippings with free
returns by going to movement
mvmt.com garbage one more time get a pen
write it down there you go mvmt.com
let's talk about mint mobile mint mobile
let's talk about cutting out the middle
man quitting screwing around getting
your life together and paying 15 a month
for your cell phone service yeah I got
Patty sniffing around on that I know
she's like what's the deal with that men
mobile is there hidden fees and charges
I'm like no you dumb broad it's 15 a
month let's go straighten her the [ __ ]
out what are you trying to get her to
cut the cord from those big box bozos I
call them plus she likes that Ryan
Reynolds yeah
I'm in bed with [ __ ] who do I got I
had Sprint and they pawned me off like
I'm a two dollar hooker
I know I'm walking around trying to earn
money for T-Mobile now I don't know
what's going on but for anyone who hates
their phone bill because I do mint
mobile offers premium Wireless for just
15 bucks a month like I told you I've
been saying it for years now the bird is
a customer she's been using it since
before I even had a [ __ ] podcast yeah
that's how that's how embed I am with
mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying one for a family and at mint
family start at two lines all plans come
with unlimited talk and text high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone with any
mint Mobile plan keep your same number
along with all your existing contacts
the whole nine yards that make it easy
boom
um switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
beans a month 15 clams 15 smokes 15
whatevers that's two gallons of gas with
these prices uh get premium wire get
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month and no unexpected plot twist at
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage seriously you'll
make your wallet very happy at
mintmobile.com garbage do it do it the
second thing uh was my uh I was I was I
was jerking off one day and I was
jerking off yeah is this before this is
after after I was jerking off when I was
fat like with two fingers like it was
only I had my dick my at The Acorn my
dick stomach was very big sure so but it
boots your pouch yeah my little uh fupa
the mound my bush fat yeah so your mouth
I actually this is the old mountain I
was jerking off and I had I had my dick
in my hand and then I got to go like
this all right double handed it I double
handed it I mean I had to push down a
little bit sure yeah we're all gentlemen
here Bobby you're not straight [ __ ]
two-handed it not straight to him come
on I'm a [ __ ] Shane Gillis yeah I got
the my piece was back and I I I I was
like my dick's back I mean it's it's a
lot it's you know a bunch of different
colors from being in a war for [ __ ]
eight years everyone was underground for
a decade yeah I mean like a turnip it's
got PTSD I got a [ __ ] leave it in the
sun for like a little bit yeah get some
lights coloring with water once
everything it looks like when a lake
dries up you can see the different
little wrinkles yeah yeah I gotta get
the life back into it yeah
from three inches of [ __ ] just Brown
Puerto Rican [ __ ] and then the rest is
just White and the top is red like
Rudolph's nose [ __ ] dinosaur fossils
in there
yeah but it's my dick's back there you
go fantastic I mean that'll put just
even more pep in your step ah dude
knowing you wake up you still got a
[ __ ] root going do you feel like
you're a little more chubbed up these
days down there like my sack Stripes
back I mean my wife it's bad timing
because she's pre-menopausal so she
wants nothing to do with it but you know
when I go to those massage parlors those
chicks are [ __ ] they're all on board
look at this
yeah I didn't get that for a while
uh yeah it's back there's a lot of good
things though about it man I mean just
being able to sleep you don't understand
how much sleep
I do I do now since I got the machine
when I got until I got a sleep apnea
machine yeah before that the dude was
like bro you probably having a decent
night's sleep in seven years it's crazy
and now I use it religiously in the
beginning I was a little off little lawn
it was uncomfortable it was this I
wasn't washing it right which I got a
[ __ ] terrible [ __ ] uh like sinus
infection cold a few weeks ago yeah but
now I use it [ __ ] religiously and it
it's a game changer it's a game changer
but losing the weight is better than the
Sleep sure I mean I sleep I sleep on my
back now like I used to have to sleep on
my side or I used to get that fat
position oh yeah pillow between the legs
holding a pillow two pillows dude my
knees would hurt because my fat leg was
on my other leg hurting himself yeah it
was bad dude it was bad so now I feel
fantastic I feel fantastic awesome yeah
I wasn't going to tell anybody but I'm
like there's too many [ __ ] that
are like me that I know or that might
that are like because it's the biggest
decision ever sure because you don't
want to get it I'm one of them what do
you mean I'm one of them and that took
me that that took me by surprise when
you told me that right and I was like
[ __ ] man because I told you my
pulmonologist said it the cardiologist
said it and I'm like I don't want to do
that did that and then you were like
dude I wish you wish you would have done
it 10 years ago everybody I talked to
for the last three years because I know
a lot of people it's like being gay and
it also because I know a lot of people
and I can't like out them sure you know
what I mean but I take a lot to come out
you know and say that 100 you know what
I mean yeah 100 there's probably tons of
guys that we know that that had it that
oh yeah just worked out did this did
that oh I would do that for sure really
oh I would lie to everyone lose 60
pounds in two weeks I'd be taking
pictures of marathons and stuff that I
didn't run I'd be [ __ ] I'd really be
Hamming it up that's why I started
photoshopping me in the gym just walking
around with the trophy yeah I got a
medal yeah Jiu Jitsu medals not doing it
all
yeah exactly you got a [ __ ] black
belt with three red stripes and a dragon
I would that no for sure I wouldn't tell
anybody just because I want the let me
ask you this is it covered under your
insurance yes so you'd have to pay out
of pocket no I think it would be covered
under mine as well it's it's covered
under most I feel it's covered under
most but um the you know the process of
it doing it it was it was shameful
because I was like I'm a man you know I
gotta sure and I just couldn't do it but
then I'm like I know guys use
testosterone and steroids because they
gonna that's how they get their [ __ ]
together yeah I went to rehab for drugs
and alcohol 37 years ago so I was like
it's like going to rehab it's like I get
but I can't I can't just go away for
three months it's like my stomach is in
rehab right now and I get to go live my
life sure do what the [ __ ] I'm supposed
to do and it gives me that little a
governor that just helps me because I I
still have to work out every day I walk
and I lift weights and that's it and
then I I eat right I quit caffeine I
quit sugar but it gave me that ability
to give you two weeks off yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
I just cleaned my system out uh
completely so and also I what if it
didn't work what if I [ __ ] two weeks
in I just started eating like a Savage
that happens that could happen dude
people you have to really people eat
themselves out of it right they break
the band they like they've heard Ralphie
May went through two bands damn he did
the band surgery he ate through it you
can you can and even this in two years
your stomach can get big again if you
wanted to so it's uh yeah it's not just
like a cure there's a lot of work that
goes along with it yeah dude I'd be
helping you live a healthier life I do
10 20 000 steps a day and you feel full
when you eat you have a little dinner
same thing as before so what you eat
you'll have like a little piece of
chicken and now I can eat whatever I
want if I you know what I mean I can
have anything so you can have a little
piece of chicken vegetables and stuff
like that but all of a sudden you're
just full and when we go to the dinner I
just go I just put it aside and I go
I'll take that home and I'll eat it the
next day I'll have lunch the next day so
I you know it's like you we used to get
appetizers two appetizers a salad the
bread sure the cappuccino and then a
whole meal would come and then I'd
[ __ ] devour that I'd try a little of
my wives yeah that's dinner steal some
of Max's french fries there you go yeah
I now just get a piece of fish a couple
things of vegetables maybe a little
piece of potato and I'm out I'm just
done I eat slower now smaller bites but
I it's there's no more what are we going
for lunch what are we doing for dinner
tonight I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't care anymore because it's
like food isn't my best friend anymore
it's not like you know I'm on the road
and it I'm not like what am I gonna
where am I I don't give a [ __ ] I just
need a little bit of something I'm done
keep it moving keep it moving dude keep
it moving because I'm telling you it
does the same [ __ ]
as alcohol does to your body inside
let's not get crazy I'm telling you
alcohol is all right alcohol never hurt
anybody this guy's obviously a quack
over here but [ __ ] believe this guy
get out of here
I'm in here trashy my favorite thing in
the world not not regular alcoholics
like the bad ones
people who are real alcoholics you get
the cirrhosis of the liver you get fatty
liver sure fat people get the same [ __ ]
I had fatty liver just like I was
drinking too much like Pate Pate um Pate
is so good dude we went to [ __ ] when
I did that tour with I did this great
tour too I set it up to where I went uh
with Louis to Europe before I got to
surgery so yeah one final run dude did
you buddy it's like prom night baby dude
I was [ __ ] everything over there like
Henry Hill before he went to the can do
we we went we got fried we got uh I'll
take me to get my sleeve
zucchini flowers with fragua in it and
then fried
I mean you bit it and the Frog wire just
melted down your face dude chicken skin
with cream and then caviar on top what
are you doing to him he doesn't have the
sleeve man he's gonna be eating the
table in a second I'm hard as a rock
what are you Bobby you're gonna kill the
god dude I got carbonara by a castle in
Rome it comes it comes in the [ __ ]
the the skillet they don't even put it
on the plate they just give you the
skillet
and cacia pepe the guy goes what do you
want to go Acacia Pepe and carbonara and
give me that [ __ ] antipasto too
stuffed my face I mean I had a food
glorious tour before I and then three
days later I came back I lost weight
though over there from walking so much
came back three days later two days
after that three days after the surgery
I was at the premiere of Fourth of July
right that's what you guys saw yeah yeah
so
it was uh I I did it the right way I
planned it out perfectly and then right
after that I won a country to the tiny
house for two months I was away from
Comedy let the heat blow off I wasn't
around any of the [ __ ] I was just
walking every day hiking kayaking
fishing there was no [ __ ] um I went
up to JFL for a little bit but I wasn't
around any of the [ __ ] but now it's good
it's [ __ ] great dude it's the best
thing I ever did I wish I did it I wish
I did it three years ago when I thought
about it okay I wish I did it then
because I would be ahead of the game
right now it's a game changer and I know
I know a lot of people who did it that
are in the closet with it which is cool
I'm cool with that but they're they all
said the same thing it's the best thing
I ever did cool yeah so if you need help
thank you I'm here for you you give me
that number that [ __ ] chicken skin
joint yeah
where in Rome was this yeah where's this
Castle
[Music]
get my night suit Toby
I hope nothing happens I hope nothing
happens what do you mean we're gonna cut
back to this thing and yo with Keith hey
yeah you guys here maybe you're missing
a foot yeah he's like Papa you come in
and do the show with me we can't
understand him anymore you're gonna need
to be fat again because I got to make
fat jokes
oh Bobby's a good replacement when you
go all right here we go
party congrats thank you it's awesome
you got the special out the [ __ ]
movie this summer which everybody's
great I mean yeah let's sit here and
blow you were fantastic in the movie
killer killer just such a [ __ ] great
actor but also comedically great thank
you buddy it was a great movie it was
great I loved it what I loved about that
movie is that he did that Premiere at
the Beacon that was one of my favorite
yeah it was just a great great night
looking out and seeing every single
person I knew every comic
open micers Headliners we all showed up
for for that night it was so it was epic
to me it was great I mean I was [ __ ]
hurting because I just got out of
surgery and everybody was trying to hug
me I'm like get the [ __ ] off me uh but
it was a stomach over here yeah get away
it was uh it was that's why I love New
York yeah I love Comics it was a really
cool really cool night for sure great
night fantastic night it was a fun
experience man we couldn't be happier
for you gang do yourself a favor all
this is at Louis ck.com you got the all
the seasons of Louis that Bobby's in you
got Fourth of July and you got the brand
new special
get mine first
he's in all of it what do you mean he's
not wetting his beef accomplished man
you plug in a better comedian relax
specials they're also on there check
those Louie's got three houses I got a
three bedroom ranch with no basement
help me what the [ __ ] you talking about
I just got stomach surgery I need new
clothes you Cox I'm going to Walmart
this guy's shopping at Walmart you're
plugging a millionaire you get to Eat
Fried Chicken I'm [ __ ] eating
breasted chicken only a quarter I
figured you'd wet your beak on
everything I don't know wet my big Woody
and nuts wet my beak on the show Louie I
got [ __ ] eight bucks for Fourth of
July
oh my God Gang This is a family episode
as you know when um when you sign up to
the patreon there you can have your
question right on the air we got Mr
Robert Kelly here uh to answer some of
those questions for you mm-hmm
Gippy okay
[Laughter]
all right this one's from Blake Smith
what's up boys brand new ten dollar
homie here shout out to it is it garbage
to move to a new house and bring the
entire cabin of full expired food and
spices you do that to go to a new house
and bring the old food yeah it's not
it's garbage if you bring the old
furniture yeah I think you [ __ ] put
that [ __ ] on the lawn they get a brand
new leopard couch for 200 bucks get a
leopard couch an old bottle of Lowry's
yeah yeah dude you get you get rid of
everything the only thing you're
bringing I mean I don't even say bring
the mattress just bring the bed frame
yeah you bring [ __ ] that's hard to get
or you know furniture from your dead
Grandma it's like yeah something that
has like a like a piece rather than like
oh this is the couch we were just using
it's like yeah get a new couch get it on
this and also I don't like moving [ __ ]
I'll go I'll [ __ ] pay the guy to
deliver it the new one start fresh yeah
whole nine I don't want to rap the [ __ ]
I don't want to be in there wrapping
dumb glasses and put them in the box I
make sure the two times we moved I was
away I booked myself away because I know
my wife had to do all that [ __ ] I'm like
yeah bananas in Jersey babe I can't make
it I'm staying over
35 minutes away I gotta stay here need
me at the club early at the stress
Factory for a week yeah tell me when
it's done moving is the worst one of the
worst transitions of life it's so
stressful once you get everything in
there though it's all right yeah but get
rid of it yeah toss it yeah we brought
the stuff start fresh leave all those
old memories all that old [ __ ] because
it's not like nobody's got a ten
thousand dollar couch here like I gotta
you know move this in yes we're all
sitting on something from [ __ ]
Wayfair that has come and [ __ ] pizza
sauce on it I mean who are we fooling
here we brought the stuff we moved uh
last summer from a one bedroom into a
two bedroom
um in the same building we took
everything in the freezer oh that's a
different thing hang on one second
that's different that's the same
building you're taking an elevator
upstairs okay that's a difference so you
were quite poor at that time yeah yeah
dude throwing away your egos yeah if you
needed that hamburger meat that's a 15
minute move
the super does it yeah you know we're
talking about when I moved from 47th
Street to Westchester okay when I moved
from LA to New York you don't take [ __ ]
you left the ice trays yeah you [ __ ]
throw them off you toss every get it the
[ __ ] I was when I was in LA and we were
selling our stuff to move I had all this
furniture out in the lawn all this stuff
and uh no one was buying anything and
the lady comes out she goes do you have
like jackets socks like shirts like old
stuff that you I was like I was going to
give it to Goodwill she goes no put it
out in the grass everything's a buck and
you know uh all the people will come
because it was kind of a low budget area
we were living in they need that [ __ ]
and so they'll come all of a sudden
packed everything is gone everything I
sold a pair of socks for 50 cents uh Dom
DeLuise bought my I swear to God wait
who Dom [ __ ] DeLuise okay do you know
who that is all right listen I knew
you're gonna cop a dude I know the name
you know that I know the name I don't
know [ __ ] Clint Eastwood I know we
shouldn't be buying your socks I know
that I didn't buy my socks he bought my
egg cooker
oh my God he bought my microwave I feel
like I've heard this before what the
[ __ ] I haven't heard this he bought my I
look up there's a two to a Lincoln
[ __ ] Seville or whatever the [ __ ] it
is I look over it's Dom DeLuise a little
scally cap little chubby dude I walk up
and go dumb he's like hey do you want my
egg cooker no he goes he goes how much
for the I had two of them I had a brand
new one that you microwave and one that
you plug in and they cook eggs and he
goes how much for the egg thing kid and
I go take the the microwave one it's
brand new he goes I don't like microwave
stuff I want the other one I go put this
egg on it he goes I don't care I go even
better yeah free lunch he literally
starred in a movie called Fatso my
favorite movie
best movie of all time uh I want to
remake it with you okay yeah don't get
the surgery yet I'm in if you get yeah I
want you to be one of the Chubby Checker
remember the Chubby Checkers uh
they came up when he was they called
them and they come in the big fat guys
come in and they were he over ate and
they come in they talk to him and
they're sitting down oh and they're
talking about like you ever get a jelly
down and suck the jelly out and put
chocolate in it yeah and they're like
well did you ever get then they started
going over the food uh Wars they started
going back in the memories yeah yeah
yeah and then like get the honey you can
have a little honey in this junior and
he's like we can't we don't have honey
you can't have honey and like get the
honey Junior music but you can't dump
and the guy goes get the honey and then
they just rip apart the kitchen they
push him out of the way they punch his
stomach the keys pop out of his mouth
yeah the best [ __ ] is going on the best
movie if you're a fat [ __ ] it was a
Cannonball Run you never saw Cannonball
Run oh my God what did you see five
Italian movies from Scorsese that's it
and just watch The Godfather you just
didn't hey did you tell me what's the
Godfather the other day yeah I had
mentioned I watched it not for the first
time I watched it on the plane
I didn't watch it for the first time
okay fair enough you never saw the movie
Fatso no what year did it come out this
is another 1980. yeah I was born in 86
what I I'm
like I was a Three Stooges fan I wasn't
born in the 40s yeah dude I mean that's
a color from the 40s yes
30s or 40s really what do you think it
was from the 70s yeah what do you think
right before it Ghostbusters yeah I like
creature double feature I wasn't around
during that time I mean yeah no I mean
also like I don't think Fatso was a
classic that are you out of your mind on
the Academy Award
[Laughter]
[Music]
his cousin directed it the his sister in
the movie and it's shot all in the West
Village by the seller that's where he
grew up his family grew up over there
it's based on his family because they're
all fat [ __ ] Italians so yeah okay it's
like a true story if you're a fat if
you're a fatty that you need to watch
that movie that's like your movie okay
check it out he's standing by that's
your Passion of the Christ yeah I'm
telling you dude Angels and Demons
there's so many fat moments I mean the
beginning of the movie his fat cousin
died he's huge and uh he they're like go
get Grandma a glass of water he goes in
the thing and they stir in the sauce and
he's crying so bad no one cries better
than Dom DeLuise in a movie he's crying
then he dips the sauce yeah he starts
dips the bread and the sauce and then he
pours cheese on it and he takes a bite
and it all goes he's like and it just
goes away I'm like oh I've been there so
many [ __ ] times but uh yeah so uh
anyways yeah Dom DeLuise
uh pulled up and he bought the plug-in
one not the microwavable you're about to
plug in with eggs on it and he goes what
do you do for uh living kid now go I'm a
stand-up comedian he goes haha
yeah it was so saddy I thought you know
I thought maybe you wanted to take me in
the car get a hand job or something I
get an autograph also but isn't that a
that's like such a
sad like Dom DeLuise this movies you
love his movies movie stars yeah you're
old they cooker buying old egg cookers
it's the greatest thing ever I don't
know are you nuts yeah God sent him to
me
that's a that's a that's a universe
thing that's a I made it I said it's
more sad for dumb not you no why you met
me nice these guys are successfully
driving around buying a used egg cooker
dude he went home and he cooked some
eggs he could buy into egg cooker I made
it easier so the greatest movie of all
time yeah it was in the 80s this was
[ __ ] 97. he had no money at that
point Burt Reynolds told him to go [ __ ]
himself looking for a used George
Foreman girl I helped him out what the
[ __ ] he's into a Seville Lincoln it's
not a Mercedes he's driving American
he's not that rich I pictured him with a
driver to be honest with you I did too
no he pulled up it was great uh I
[ __ ] love Dom DeLuise
all right well yes that sounds added to
the list sell your [ __ ] okay do not take
spices a spice that reminded me my mom
bought our shore house and I was for
years we've had it like 10 years now at
this point and I was like these are
expired she kept the spices from the
previous Jesus and I was like why do we
have this she goes oh that was here from
when we bought the house I'm like
[ __ ] torched this place this is why I
mean someone else's pepper that's weird
yeah oh wait really from oh my gosh they
left their spices in I'm like all this
shit's old she goes oh I don't know that
was in there when we bought that house
yeah sell the cans they're worth money
oh yeah they're probably super old
school catch an old bullion Cube yeah
McHenry up not dissolve mchenry's pepper
can't it's worth a thousand dollars yeah
it's like an old Rolex lemon pepper salt
lemon juice lemon pepper was always in
the back of the spice thing we never
[ __ ] with it it would always get cakey
and stick together ever see lemon pepper
I didn't [ __ ] with peppers I like garlic
pepper garlic pepper garlic salt garlic
salts all right garlic pepper garlic God
that's a good one that's good yeah I
like it all right
well next one this one's just funny this
is from the skook is it garbage to wear
colored Tims to a construction site
because they're here they're your only
pair of boots saw a guy working on the
Queensborough Bridge in a set of red
Timbs yesterday
it was rich Voss
that's a tough look man show it out with
color coordinated Tims yeah they're low
tops on tide that's bad news that ain't
good you got to go the traditional Tims
traditional work boot Tim yeah you got a
pair of boots what are you rocking I
probably got some cool rock climber
boots I got the the you know that uh get
a set of galoshes I got the dominant gay
guy gay club boot you know with the like
the hive like up to the knee you know
those boots like a lot of gay guys wear
with chaps I got those they're like a
high heel boot but Doc Martens ah kind
of like that yeah okay yeah I don't
where'd you get them I got them from
this gay guy guys I'm driving around L.A
are you coming from Dom DeLuise keep the
boots kid thanks for the [ __ ] and the
eggs no um yeah I'm not a boot guy I
don't like Tim's I don't like the the
ones you get new sneakers at least dude
I got the best sneakers in the world
there you go what do you rocking set of
kicks
if you're a fat [ __ ] these are the 280
x 12 New Balance it's like a fighter jet
look at that [ __ ] shoe it's a slip-on
I mean if you're a fat [ __ ] and you
don't have a slip-on's tough though
because it doesn't don't you like does
it start doing this you can fold it in
and stuff no no okay
I'm not a slip-on now it's gonna fight
you know I'm not a slip-on guy he's not
gonna be able to get his shoe back on
until we hit him with the shoe cam real
quick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we have the fat guy Olympics
what's the socks and shoes time
I think he just broke the record yeah
you have to do it without sitting on the
bed
yeah I don't I don't did anybody with
colored coordinated anything kind of
bugs me yeah I feel like that's back in
the day that was like early 2000s that
that got real big in the and at least in
like the hip-hop like it was like the
Hat match the shirt which matched the
shoe like once shoes got real like shoes
and jerseys and all that chick and hats
got cool yeah black guys look like
skateboarders did back in the day now
you know what I mean they got some weird
shoes some Nike colorful oh they I can't
I can't stay up on the Nike the the cool
shoe Trend like Yani does it Yanni's got
some cool kicks I don't like that
because you like you're with somebody
with nice sneakers and if it rains out
they like they have to run to the car I
did it last night actually they got
hemmed up was that when a new pair of
shoes and it was raining I was like
we're gonna take an Uber home it was
like three blocks
my wife's like we are not that's silly
to me I know they were expensive how
expensive 150 bucks that's not [ __ ]
expensive
I just shot 400 at Walmart
over here sneakers you just get them wet
you're supposed to get them [ __ ] up I
know but it was more like I just got on
it was like the third time I wore them I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] about shoes I
don't care we're just bragging about
your shoes
I'm talking plantar fasciitis that's
[ __ ] Hammer but you know as a bigger
guy you get your shoes wet you're in
trouble those shoes are done it's like
Nam because they're gonna start kicking
they're gonna start stinking it's gonna
be a bad scene yeah toss them get a
Brand New Pair he doesn't do that though
he doesn't keep up good maintenance what
do you mean I just play a little cologne
in there and put them by their radiator
[ __ ] shoe yeah and make them smell
good like a guinea
I don't know what the Italian Americans
like a French [ __ ] walking around there
you can [ __ ] you're gonna hook a shoe
I do if I took these off they'd be
kicking yeah I don't do that I toss them
good [ __ ] buy okay yeah I used to
having a guy a friend of mine in the
mafia and every time he went to his
house he make you take your socks off
make sure you're not wearing a wire
that's what I was that was my first
thought like Donny brace no he he had a
closet full of brand new socks and he
made you put new socks on he's like
there's no reason you should wear dirty
socks I don't hate that it's cheap
enough you can buy a pair of socks
having your thing wearing a pair of new
socks every day every day is a lot but a
little I think you're right that's a lot
but I'm in I like it as soon as the sock
gets a little goodbye throw it out yeah
I just started doing that what is it six
bucks for 12. I just re-upped on the
socks throughout all my old ones and put
a whole fresh fresh thing there's
nothing better than fresh socks a fresh
sock a fresh pair of underwear fresh
socks fresh on these
I mean whatever you're wearing on the
outside on the on the inside you feel
good feel good yeah I just bought a
fresh set of Goodfellows from [ __ ] to
a man are you a Good Fellows man what
the [ __ ] is good fella it's like their
brand targets brand do their underwear
socks are [ __ ] awesome they're good
do yourself a favor and you know what
you could get some stuff cheap stuff in
the meantime over there at Target the
Goodfellow brand they have all kinds of
nice shirts and joggers and [ __ ] like
that are they a sponsor of the show no
oh really we're just a fan wow that's
awesome from me check out butcher box
but I'm just saying you know that's me
me my [ __ ] [ __ ] can't have meat
have you been listening wait you can I
can eat meat but I can't I'm gonna buy a
whole box of it took me six years it'll
be 98 making [ __ ] steak tips how did
you break the news to uh Dom steak tips
that you're out of the game they're
probably closing right now
hammering in a [ __ ] piece of plywood
Like A hurricane's coming no I could
it was all good to that Bobby went and
got that goddamn sleeve you got to think
about that too you're gonna shut down
you're you're gonna you're gonna
financially impact a lot of business
there's a class action lawsuit of a
bunch of Deli workers
one of my best friends Paul G just I
mean it's sad it made me he just opened
a pizza place it's been my dream my
whole life to have a good friend that
had a pizza place where I could just
walk just get a pizza place and I go in
there now and I can't eat I don't know
that's sad no yeah I could still have
steak tips I can just have one yeah yeah
it's it's kind of sucks I ain't gonna
pay to rent up in Boston unfortunately I
I do miss that yeah you gotta be careful
though look at you guys you're making me
relapse I don't [ __ ] rip through this
in the afternoon he's gonna be on
ubereats on the way out of here make you
feel guilty you can see me in a Ramen
Shop
yeah no it's uh I I can eat whatever I
want but I can have just one steak tip
which does suck you ever have steak tips
uh I don't know I gotta I should have
brought a bag I have I have a freezer in
my I should I should give you guys my my
old clothes and all my old clothes and
your old steak tips yeah you got any
spices too I'll take them I'll be
telling the story in 20 years Bobby
Kelly steak tips right here
he pulled up in a pair of New Balance
x-29s I'm telling you right now
you said that like they were government
issues you dropped the model number the
skew the whole nine years yeah any fat
guy knows 1080 1080 [ __ ] 12s of the
sneaker to go
it's the fat guy sneaker Nike stink
too thin
it's like you need them wider I need a
wide shoe yeah and I need a lot of
cushion a lot of cushion yeah the Nike
the flat bottom is like wearing a high
heel for a fat guy I usually do this uh
one type of Adidas I can't think of the
what model it is but they're they're
pretty cushiony what size shoe are you
uh 11 and a half 12. I get a big piece
no you don't have a big dick nah really
it's in there it's okay but it's also
underground yeah hibernate yeah it's off
the grid yeah laying it low playing it
right no credit cards no stuff six
months it would be nice if I was a much
skinnier when I was younger it was great
yeah but now it's uh yeah it's gone it's
bogged it'll come back yeah you'll get
it divorce all that kind of stuff couple
Investments didn't go his way he's uh
he's not doing what's his shirt and
Bitcoin the housing market really
cleaned them out yeah Shibu Inu [ __ ]
took him out
[ __ ] Louis Gomez that [ __ ] sucker
making me think dude you're gonna get
about doggy get Shibu emo [ __ ]
[ __ ] nah but he's in there he's
all right yeah he's coming back yeah
yeah can you see him I see him every
once in a while nights and weekends you
have to look at each other like prison I
talked to him on the phone
I'll see you later
put an iPad down to your face over a
bread truck
a poor little guy um all right let's see
here this one's from Tracy McGrady ever
get a massage at the mall 100 really
like in the chair with your head's in
that thing sometimes they have them now
because the malls are empty like
whatever they're a store yeah and you go
in it's like you know I don't know I
can't get him I smell [ __ ] pretzels
cooking yeah Auntie Anne's right down
the block dude I gotta I got a big mess
I'll go to those chop shops where it's
like a dollar a minute and I went to one
up here and uh the guy brought me in put
me down the thing and then 20 minutes in
I looked down there was just guy feet in
the women's flip-flops
and I looked up and he goes we were busy
keep going I have one I use a girl I
have a girl I a woman I use in my
neighborhood and I guess she couldn't
make it yeah so they sent her I'm
guessing husband Rocco who came from
another job like he had like work boots
on he had a second
he had a set of keys on his and like a
club foot so like he like his he would
walk around he's in the middle of a loop
job dude it was bad yeah oil over your
back I still got the handy but you know
calluses on your phone oh dude it was no
amount of oil would would soak up it was
still like grip tape on in my back it
was bad I went to uh I'll go to I I've
been to I got it though at the airport I
got though in but I didn't get just the
chair when I went in the back room
that's all right airport you're
traveling yes you got to release it you
got time a layover I've done it in a
mall [ __ ] some fat lady next to me
getting one I tried to get a hand job in
one of those in the mall you can't do it
at the mall Bobby yes you can you go two
hours just legs breaks them down like
I'm not doing too [ __ ] here just what
you want you're out in 15 hours just
like two hours just legs keep your
reservation at the Cheesecake Factory
I like what's going on with the malls
these days they're actually pretty fun
they got those kinds of places they have
the uh the BB gun shooting galleries
there's usually Dave and Busters because
they're all tanking so now like they use
like it's like experience it's kind of
fun like the game like the arcades and
like they want people to go to like do
stuff rather than chop yeah you go uh
the Palisades Mall
yeah it's my mom where are you I'm in
Washington Heights okay yeah I'm right
by the gwb but I like getting out get
hop in the car go to like an actual mall
rather than doing 50 different stores
they got the movie theater right they
got the go-karts The Comedy Club they
got the rock climb yeah they got the uh
what else ice skating rink now whoa yeah
they got a nice skating rink in there
they have the monkey the monkey things
yeah no I'll never
it's like a [ __ ] trapeze climbed tank
because it's like a four-story mall
which I don't like by the way because
you get lost on the floors of like
what's where and [ __ ] like yeah but I
like that I love getting lost in a mall
but they have a rock wall no but it's
like it's in the you'll hurry up you get
into a harness like a rope that's the
best side it's a ropes course yeah it's
like uh you walk around but it's like
five stories high yeah oh I need to [ __ ]
that they have a ferris wheel Ferris
wheel food court kind of sucks food
court blows they used to be no
Chick-fil-A no Chick-fil-A but they do
have a Chipotle which is all right yeah
but every Mall should have a [ __ ]
Chick-fil-A you should have a
Chick-fil-A and you'll remember this in
Orange Julius remember an Orange Julius
I do remember that that's that's old
school Mall yeah that's like first Mall
it should be a sparrow in your food
tomorrow yeah I love it like crazy a
slice of pizza at the mall just for
Comfort there's got to be a sparkle
first of all they're this big they're
great you get two of them and a large
dog a large Diet Coke called a day I I
like the the the sushi place with the
spinning thing where you just grab the
plate and they charge you by the call of
the plate oh I don't know that dude
that's at the Palisades Mall that's Sea
World Bobby what are you in the VIP
section
you're right I'll take three bunkers
dude
Sarah get off the table please
if you miss something you're chasing it
down
it's like the luggage rack at the
airport
running around me and Patrice California
rolls mine get out of there check the
tags on it it's mine
at the sushi place at that mall fourth
floor you um you there's fourth floor is
wild it's nuts fourth floor it just goes
around like like the luggage thing at
the airport and you just grab one around
the whole Mall no yeah yeah you sit
anywhere no it's in the [ __ ]
restaurant now I'm down here next to
Macy's waiting on a goddamn spring are
you getting a massage
no I know I I know you mean I don't
think I've ever I've never been I've
never seen one of those in the mall but
I've seen them the best sushi place ever
because the guy's just making sushi and
you're right here and the conveyor
belt's right here so you just see
something you grab it and you eat it and
then they come and just add up your
plates blue paint green plate red plate
and it's different prices two dollars
five dollars whatever right and you just
eat as much as you want you have to like
you don't have to order hey can we get
another one of these yeah you could you
can just overeat and nobody knows it's
just uh like it looks like you're doing
dishes
[Laughter]
Patrice actually made a place in Vegas
changed the rules it was it was all you
eat sushi and the [ __ ] was like she
went you have to finish what's on your
plate before you order again and we were
like where's that rule she goes now it's
the rule they made the rule she wrote it
on a piece of paper and like stuck it up
because we were just [ __ ] we had like
seven thousand dollars worth it sure
yeah just take them to the [ __ ]
cleaners yeah it was great awesome uh
what was it like when was your last
official bang bang with Louie
with Louie yeah isn't that how you did
it with oh I did it on the show but not
not with him uh who would you do it with
I would do it with myself a lot dude I
remember I mean I think my last official
was BonChon
bonchun I'm sorry okay I apologize no
problem I know you [ __ ] yeah I got a
nickel in the company I had a stock in
the company you racist I say BonChon you
say BonChon sure Korean chicken
is it it's BonChon in the goddamn United
States of America boy goddamn bonjon all
right yeah called Barry Williamson you
[ __ ] communist yeah
um yeah BonChon at BonChon and then I
went and got uh a club sandwich with
french fries
they're just so strange what I just I
really wanted a club sandwich but then
there was a bunch and I was like I have
to get the [ __ ] box you gotta pop it
it's the best fried chicken in the world
yeah there's no other fried I mean it's
better than what what chicken beats
BonChon what Korean Fried Chicken's
pretty awesome it's the [ __ ] hi that
was BonChon Thai no it's a Korean no
it's Korean Fried Chicken you're looking
like I'm crazy I don't know I don't like
the fact he corrected his [ __ ]
pronunciation but you don't even know
what country it's [ __ ] yeah it's one
it's over there oh yes I mean that's
what I was saying BonChon who gives a
[ __ ]
Toby
I got no clue just tell me we're doing a
goddamn podcast over here
and you screwed me on the.net by the way
um all right let's see let's we gotta
bang out a couple more of these this
one's from uh rwm are you garbage if you
entirely cut up your steak before eating
it yes
that's crazy I would I'd [ __ ] leave
the table Yeah if somebody did that I
just learned that you're not not just
but learned it way too late in life that
you're not supposed to do that I've
returned a steak because they cut it
whoa why would they cut it because it
was their thing like are they sliced it
they sliced it for me I'd be okay with
that [ __ ] you [ __ ] you this is what I'm
here when you get a steak it I want to
see that [ __ ] I want to see what
I'm about to eat I want to go here and
then maybe go over there was it still
together when you got it though it was
[ __ ] filleted like they sliced it and
then put it out and made a presentation
okay yeah [ __ ] you you get a steak you
want it to hit that table
as is
and then I cut my steak okay if you
don't you don't cut your steak because
first of all if you cut the steak you're
letting the juices out
so it stops cooking true you you want
that thing to when you cut it it's hot
inside if you cut it open now it's cold
so you're eating a [ __ ] cold steak
it's stupid you're supposed to cut it as
you eat it and then every bite is a
little is warm I like it I'll give you
that what do you get in your steak
medium rare what do you think medium
rare I don't like people get rare say
[ __ ] just go yeah go bite a cow uh I
like medium rare yeah if you cut it all
up and then eat it that's that's that
psychopath Behavior yeah that's crazy I
was doing that for a long time cut the
whole thing off everything you cut the
[ __ ] steak nah I mean what are you
Jeffrey Dahmer I've had to say not this
not steak now I don't not anymore but it
took me a while I think my wife was like
made fun of me and I was like oh yeah I
totally know what I'm talking about good
for her yeah yeah good for her she's a
little refined how do you do you hold
the night how do you hold a knife in
Fork like this
do you do like the is the fork the fork
upside down upside down like that I'm
sure what I mean no I I hold the fork
like one way is the fork the fork is
facing down facing down sure I put it in
the thing what is the back of the
underside of the fork facing me right
here where's the front the front is
facing you you could do both yeah I
think the back's classy I think you
could do both yeah you could do both the
inverted you probably shirted but I like
the way it kind of the knife goes shorts
I'm with it because if it goes that way
it kind of goes a little off to the side
you cut it and then you put in your
mouth okay or if you're a real man you
[ __ ] eat it like this like a dick
don't forget to cut the balls from the
back you suck on that steak I love a
steak you get the mutton chop yet what
Keynes now oh no it's old lamb it's a
mutton chop really it's King it's right
up the streets I know Kings it's the
best the only they only started allowing
women going there like 10 years ago I
stopped going I mean kinda yes I think
30 years ago they were like all right
it's all clay pipes on the ceiling yeah
from back in the day all these famous
people was a men's it was a men's
Steakhouse they make a really good uh
what's it called wedge salad the blue
cheese wedge salad I love a wedge who
doesn't I mean who does if there's a
wedge or a Caesar let's go let's go
can't no I'm just saying like let's go
and we'll go we'll go someday
um all right just put a crouton or
something let's put a [ __ ] crew
together I have a buddy at mutton chop I
have a little piece of your wedge I'll
be done you start living through me
making me go eating places
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're filming me from a chair I'm just
licking my wife but I can only eat it
for a minute because I'm full
uh all right this one's from Cody ten
dollar buffoon here I'm gonna he's he's
asked this question a lot so we gotta
get to it uh while growing up did your
house have a designated puke bowl or
container that you would go to and use
when you got sick like if you were sick
on the couch it would bring in mine was
always the trash can from the yes from
the bathroom the little trash can from
the bathroom 100 yeah bath uh trash kit
from the bathroom came out and they put
a new bag in it yeah yeah you know so we
didn't do bags I think we just
barebacked it really I think so put a
new bag next to the couch I don't think
we had bags in it to begin with you
didn't have bags in the trash can in the
bathroom no no not at all that would
just be a special thing after 20. that
happened dude you got to put a bag you
can't puke into a [ __ ] a plastic can
we would put a bag in there when that
when that was brought up for that but
normally no there was never when you
puke you have to have a bag in it I
think we just were all dogged in Jesus
dude that's [ __ ] you throw the can out
after you kept the can the can wait a
trash can but where'd you put the Pew
he's got that much trash can where'd you
put the peel I guess he would dump it
out on the stationary tub in the in the
station or in the tub no and then push
it down utility sink maybe I don't know
I wasn't doing it that's why
because you would always see like a
Q-tip would be stuck to the bottom of it
yeah
cotton balls and [ __ ] I would get the
trash cans on the bathroom with a bag in
it okay that's good yeah or you just run
to the toilet I mean the toilet is the
puke can sure yeah but then you got to
get up you got your ice pops and [ __ ]
there's nothing shows going on but when
you're [ __ ] puking in the toilet you
get to just lie there in the cold floor
in between people's floor is nice
there's nothing better than a bathroom
tile floor and then the bottom of the
bowl is usually a little cold with some
some condensation splash some water on
your face yeah take a sip take a sip of
water rehydrate really clean yourself
out uh well this kid's they used to use
a bowl of Tupperware and then he said
also bonus garbage did your mom use that
same Bowl to make macaroni
to reuse that bowl that's insane I mean
your mom your ma I mean that's that's
crazy mom [ __ ] right there yeah I mean
nothing against your mom dude but she
didn't love you
I mean am I I'm saying macaroni I mean
dude taking it first of all a Tupperware
it's a lot of puke
like salad bowls I used like a big
mixing oh that's the worst dude that's
like sloshing around oh [ __ ] that damn
some animals out there I mean that's
just nuts and the bowl it hits the you
need a can you need it to go to the
bottom hit flat yeah you can't that
could Ricochet out hit the cat in the
face you know what I mean now she's
puking oh the toilet is the best the
toilets everything goes away real quick
just like it never happened do you have
it this happened to me yesterday I did
uh Christie's podcast over there shout
out to Chrissy D the best and then uh
love them uh Giannis too I love you
honest wish they get back together love
Yanni come on kids let's work it out
um why did something happen
I had to take a [ __ ] so bad I got
nauseous while I was [ __ ] oh that'll
happen that's a dilemma yeah wow what do
you do
man it's a game time decision you got to
see what you can quell faster what did
you do I'll tell you what I did because
I'm a pro you [ __ ] [ __ ] was puke between
your legs Bobby can do that now
I [ __ ] under my balls brought Yanni In
you got to see this
your [ __ ] flush immediately right if you
can you wipe a little bit if not you're
all right
and then you you puke or and this was at
Christie's house yeah but I didn't puke
I just had the the puke mouth the saliva
yeah yeah so I I [ __ ] immediately you
have to flush immediately because if
you're gonna puke and then you don't
want to puke into your [ __ ] because this
[ __ ] might come back up and now you get
puke [ __ ] in your face I'm aware been
there baby the great punk band named
[ __ ] in my face yeah I like their early
stuff so I I flushed [ __ ] [ __ ] flushed
spit the puke water
flushed then went back down [ __ ] the
rest
wiped and then spit again flushed washed
good to go Jesus all at someone else's
house that's crazy if not the other
alternative you puke in the sink wow
your family just puking a plain bucket
of it's right there yeah just wash that
out did you reveal this to everybody in
the house if that's what happened you
say you were combing your hair or
something like that no I told her in the
shower Bobby what are you doing in there
I did turn the water on you're garbage
if you don't if you're [ __ ] at
somebody's house and you don't leave the
faucet running always that block the
noise you're a [ __ ] piece you want to
hear something real classy uh I was uh
just at my wife's house and they have my
wife's parents house and they're they
have a bathroom off like the living room
yeah which is also like you know
connected to the kitchen or whatever
like their powder room or whatever they
have when you turn the light on no when
you turn the light on they have it
hooked up that a radio starts playing so
it drowns out any sound I was like what
the [ __ ] why is this and she's like oh
that's just so you have your own like
yeah you have your noise privacy your
[ __ ] queef during dinner German Metal
Man
flame starts shooting out the front air
freshenerative Flames just Febreze with
a light up all right yeah that's great
that's [ __ ] great that's genius
that's pretty classy I have actually
bought my [ __ ] wife saw Bond doors on
some stupid you know show I'm sure she
put them on the bathroom in the guest
bathroom oh I hate that dude there's
barn doors on a guest bathroom is not
Eric what do you mean barn doors like a
sliding John like a barn that's on a
track it's like a big wooden door with
them like when you walk into a saloon
that's Saloon that's a saloon door yeah
yeah there's a house door yeah you're in
there taking this off it's just a half
seat you can see your feet in your head
well you could see that you open it up
how you doing partner I was just going I
was just being I swear to God
Saloon dogs [ __ ] that's funny when I I
went to Iraq
and I was uh what the [ __ ] was that
um I went to Iraq they don't have uh
stalls they're just holes they have
toilets like the Army like the army so I
had to go I didn't know that so I had to
go take a dump like the first night I
was there and I just held it for two
weeks 100 dude I'm just dumping with the
dude acrossing me and I'm like I don't
like peeing in front of people let alone
dropping a deuce I was like what's up
dude
and then I had to go do the show it was
like second row
he just kept looking at me like dude I
just saw you [ __ ] oh you can't bounce
back from that that's a man though those
are men oh yeah you're not the first guy
he saw [ __ ] that day yeah when you're
it's like jail rules you know what I
mean but I did tuck my packet down I
don't know what I'm saying that little
mushroom cap have your underwear pulled
all the way up to you yeah all the way
up to your waist put my jacket off my
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got his big armies taking
a load off yeah he's got his dick on the
outside of the toilet just taking a rest
peeing in the other toilet all right we
gotta wrap it up Bobby what's up buddy
pal we love you yeah I love you
congratulations thank you gang one more
time brand new special Robert Kelly kill
box Louis ck.com director by Mr Lewis or
Robert kellylive.com Robert Carey
live.com it's fantastic he's a [ __ ]
killer check it out yeah killer I didn't
know it was on that website you told me
on the phone it was I would have been
pushing Louie this whole time
foreign
Kelly killbox check it out what do you
got for me anything else you want the
folks I didn't know no nothing go get
the special I owe Louis a lot of money
and I don't want to be in debt uh it's a
great special I think it's uh [ __ ]
I'm proud of it you know sometimes you
see the stuff you do you're like [ __ ] me
this one is great it looks great uh
nothing like it and I'm proud that one
of the funniest guys walking actually
directed it and produced it and uh that
means a lot to me of course and I love
that we're all doing our own [ __ ] now
yeah we're not waiting for a yes we're
not waiting for a no we're just doing it
so and and we're all helping each other
out now which is fantastic too you know
we don't need to go on The Tonight Show
God bless it we don't need to do all
this other stuff for radio tours we just
[ __ ] go on each other's shows
everybody all everybody help each other
baby and our fans [ __ ] uh help
everybody and uh the best we just do our
own thing now so thanks for having me on
you guys the best of course buddy
hopefully you see on ykwd soon and let
me know if uh you know you'll be getting
a call I'm I'm with you I'm
[Music]
guys we're all over the road uh get some
tickets yeah come see us added some
shows in Providence out of the show in
Boston grab those ticks yes get them and
then also Atlanta then we have two shows
yeah I'm part of the red clay Comedy
Festival and then also Charlotte get
those [ __ ] Dickies gang we love
you and we'll see you next week peace